coup dès maintenant sur la situation
dans la capitale ukrainienne kiev elle
se prépare toujours à l'aso russe qui
promet d'être vaste en attendant des
habitants continuent d'organiser la
résistance intelligente des barricades
mehdi chebil est notre envoyé spécial à
maidan le coeur de kiev
nous sommes aujourd'hui au neuvième jour
de l'invasion russe en ukraine nous nous
situons au centre de kiev dans la place
de meydan c'est la grande place centrale
de la ville c'est une place qui était
vraiment en 2014 le lieu de la
révolution c'est un endroit où il y
avait des dizaines de milliers de
personnes l'euphorique pour célébrer la
chute de l'ancien régime aujourd'hui
l'atmosphère est beaucoup plus maussade
c'est une atmosphère de résistance comme
vous pouvez voir derrière moi les des
volontaires sont en train de préparer
des fortifications on va s'avancer un
petit peu
donc ce qu'on voit ici c'est des
volontaires qui remplissent des sacs de
sable qui seront ensuite amenés pour
barricader les nombreux bâtiments
officiels qui se trouvent autour de
cette place ils sont encadrés par des
membres de la défense territoriale ce
sont des réservistes c'est les personnes
qui étaient encore des civils il ya
quelques jours et qui depuis le début du
conflit se sont vus remettre des armes
et participe participent à la protection
de la ville participe à contrôler les
tchèques pointe au 9e jour de l'invasion
russe la ville est relativement calme et
les ukrainiens met à profit ce temps
pour continuer à édifier le maximum de
fortifications à travers la capitale
et ben l'instant